that's when i first met you that's what
i got from you
did you have a really good childhood i
think you have a childhood unbelievable
it's unbelievable my parents are
incredible yeah my parents are
absolutely you're very actualized and
you really have a lot of the things that
neither he or i have
what does actualize mean act like you
you you can get there and you can rally
for yourself and you have that belief
in your own power yeah we're we're
spineless little um
um kind of scared of our own um strength
i don't believe we're finally scoops
i don't believe that you guys don't
believe in your power we have a lot of
built-in same because we got beat so
much
as children yeah like every
you know we never really were rewarded
for even
anything yeah but uh yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yeah but
because how can you become so successful
what is it or do you not recognize your
own success
well it's like unless there's i i have a
perfectionist
a perfectionist kind of head i won't
even try if i don't know the result is
absolute perfection
because it's not like there's any reward
to be had
because i just was never rewarded unless
it was exactly what my parents and then
that's crippling right because then you
don't try to do certain things
yeah because you might end up failing
yeah so eventually you just become
paralyzed with all these like an
abundance of ideas you'll never
ever even pull the trigger no that is
interesting we are better about it now
but we're
but that's why i because you've tasted
success yeah and i like
literally i look at a guy like you
though and i go um because we really
are fond of you i love it thank you i
love it
i love you guys i mean i love you i i
know i know but
as soon as i met you i i was i was fond
of you and you know and i think you know
rogan all these people [ __ ] with you
too right it's it's like it's a
you know you're able to now do buy
coastal [ __ ] right yeah but they're just
you guys
you guys have embraced me more than the
new york scene has embraced me
wow really 100 west coast embraced me
way before new york that's so strange
why is that um i kind of like carved my
own path in new york like i didn't like
do like the traditional
like uh i wasn't like hitting the mics
with a lot of people and i wasn't like
for lack of a better term like really
kind of like hanging around maybe the
seller and like
um i don't want to say kiss and ass of
the ogs but like
uh i just didn't feel like that was the
best use of my time like i thought the
best use of my time was like
getting on stage as much as i possibly
could and being as funny as i possibly
could
you know and like that's what my main
focus was and i i wasn't like trying to
like cozy up to anybody to like open for
them and maybe that was interpreted as
like
not you know paying the respects or
something like that but that's never
what it was it was just like i know what
the [ __ ] i want to do i know how to
get i can get better at comedy by
working on comedy
not by telling this comic how amazing
his set was
does that make sense yeah but i but you
know for me
um my opinion about somebody is
you know i look at the work okay so it's
like
you know when i i remember when i first
met you
i don't know if i said this the last
time but i didn't know who the [ __ ] you
were right yeah i had heard your name
because i knew that you were on the list
because we were doing that show together
yeah but it couldn't put a name to the
face
so you were leaning against this like
poll yeah right and you go hey i'm
andrew yeah
and what i wanted to say i didn't say it
i don't give a
[ __ ] i love it right that's what i
wanted to say yeah but i go
like oh nice to meet you andrew or
whatever of this [ __ ] white guy right
right but as soon as you know me he i
saw him perform
right yeah there it's the same feeling
that i had when i saw patrice for the
first time oh that's the biggest
compliment where i went
oh [ __ ] that's real
right he could be the biggest piece of
[ __ ] you know i mean hopefully
his friend if he's a piece of [ __ ] i
can't be his friend right but then he
turned out to be a really nice guy as
well right
but it's like i just look at the work
right i don't know about the history or
how you got there you know i look at
what i see on stage and i go
oh [ __ ] that's high level [ __ ] right
yeah and so um that's how i you know
that's how we've that's how i know you
right right from
from the work and that's the best yeah
yeah you know
and and now you know i mean you're also
a great podcaster and we
we have a good relationship but um you
know i really do
you know you're a young kid i want to
[ __ ] hurt you sometimes
i really do when i look at the videos
you know what i mean i'm going to go i
i i don't want to get but i have to [ __ ]
with it thank you yeah i'm [ __ ] with
it
so when's the netflix when is it it's
out it's out yeah it's out now
it's uh you guys can go check it out man
it's uh schultz saves america that's
what it is yeah
yeah and then what else do you have
going on nothing
yeah are you doing a lot of stand up or
no no i haven't done any actually
either either way yeah and and weirdly
enough i haven't desired it
yeah i think like my creative juices
were fueled by this project that just
took so much [ __ ] time
yeah it was okay and then weirdly enough
like doing pods
like and hanging around not my own pod
but like doing other people's pods
especially if there's like people in the
room
i start to miss stand up a little bit